The trick is to add these two lines to the diagram.
We know the slope of this line, which is -1 over the time constant for the heat loss.
We know the length of this line, which is the jump, and the rate of change of the temperature.
The heating value times the burning rate.
This term makes the difference between burning and not burning,
and now we can use the slope to express the ratio of this leg to this leg.
1 over the time constant for the heat loss equals the ratio of the vertical length to the horizontal length.
The vertical length, the green line, is h times the burn rate and the burn rate is the wood's density
over the time constant of burning, and the horizontal length is 1,200 K minus the ambient temperature.
You solve this equation for h, plug in these numbers, and then you get 135 K/kg/m².